Benjamin Franklin, through extensive study
of the world’s major religions and various
moral codes, came up with a list of thirteen
main virtues that he felt every person should
strive to live their life by.
As such, he himself attempted to always live
by this code and developed charts with which
he charted his progress from day to day, to
make sure that he was constantly improving
towards this end.
He would start with one of the virtues and
plot his progress on the chart until he mastered
that virtue; then moving on to the next; and
so on until he mastered them all.
He ordered them specifically as shown below,
as some of them naturally lend towards others.
Thus by sticking to this order, he felt it
made it easier to achieve the whole.
This code is as follows:
Temperance: Eat not to Dullness, drink not
to elevation
Silence: Speak not but what may benefit others
or yourself.
Avoid trifling Conversation
Order: Let all your Things have their Places.
Let each Part of your Business have its Time
Resolution: Resolve to perform what you ought.
Perform without fail what you resolve.
Frugality: Make no Expense but to do good
to others or yourself: i.e.
Waste Nothing
Industry: Lose no Time.
Be always employ’d in something useful.
Cut off all unnecessary Actions
Sincerity: Use no hurtful Deceit.
Think innocently and justly; and, if you speak;
speak accordingly.
Justice: Wrong none, by doing Injuries or
omitting the Benefits that are your Duty.
Moderation: Avoid Extremes.
Forbear resenting Injuries so much as you
think they deserve.
Cleanliness: Tolerate no Uncleanness in Body,
Clothes, or Habitation
Tranquility: Be not disturbed at Trifles,
or at Accidents common or unavoidable.
Chastity: Rarely use Venery but for Health
or Offspring; Never to Dullness, Weakness,
or the Injury of your own or another’s Peace
or Reputation.
Humility: Imitate Jesus
and Socrates.